[Music]
what's worth more
a cute cat lebron james dunking or this
tweet
if you ask the internet it's the tweet
in the past year these three items were
valued online for the combined total of
4.4 million dollars
what gives them that value
it's because they're non-fundable tokens
for nfts
they represent a unique piece of media
like an image or video and they live on
a blockchain at the start of 2021 few
people had heard of nfts
by the end of the year over 24 billion
dollars had been spent on them
it's a wild potentially lucrative
marketplace why
would anyone pay 69 million dollars
for a jpeg and a hyperlink
you're afraid of missing out so it is a
frenzy but i also think in the frenzy
we're seeing the pillars of stability
grow as well
are they just overpriced digital art or
a promising technology that could
transform the way we live
the most exciting uses for nfts are
possibly things that we can't even
imagine yet
[Music]
to many the world of crypto is a foreign
universe
as bizarre as alice in wonderland
i'm alice fullwood as the economist's
finance correspondent i have spent lots
of time writing about crypto and nfts
one of my pieces was on our cover in
september with a pretty cool image
it would make a good nft right
we thought as much so we decided to sell
it as one
and down into the rabbit hole i went
three two one
in this world everyone talks in acronyms
money is cryptocurrency
and goods are nfts
an nft is a token a digital asset that
exists on a blockchain
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin are also
tokens
but bitcoins are fungible or
interchangeable
you can swap one bitcoin for another one
and still have the same thing
you can't do that with an nft
they are non-functable or unique assets
they link to the media they represent
providing an irrefutable digital
certificate of ownership
to sell ours i minted an nft linking to
our cover image and put it up for sale
on an nft auction site
and watched as the bids came through
our nft sold for 99.9 ether a
cryptocurrency commonly used by nfts
it was equivalent to about 420 thousand
dollars
we donated the net proceeds to the
economist educational foundation an
independent charity we support
but why was it worth more than the other
images of our cover going around online
the fact that our nft was the only one
minted by the economist gave it scarcity
with that came value
and purchasing it on the blockchain
meant the buyer could prove they were
the rightful owner
being able to track provenance and
monetary value has been a real game
changer for digital artists
which makes sense when one of the men
who created them is one
i've been doing digital art for a long
long time um and
got interested in it uh in the 90s you
would do internet-based projects but in
all of those cases that media kind of
goes out and it's kind of just out in
the wild right and there's no question
of economic value of that stuff for a
long time it was difficult for digital
artists to make money with their work
until blockchains like the one that
underpins bitcoin were invented that was
something that artists needed they
needed a way to be able to share their
work as they were doing but they also
needed to be able to hang on to
something so that they could have you
know be able to participate in a market
in 2014 kevin teamed up with a technical
expert anil dash to mint the world's
first nft
and present the idea to a conference
full of people
hey are you interested in some animated
gif art am i ever
i got a good i got a i got a cool thing
here check this out hey do you want to
you want to buy that yeah name your
price in any currency
maybe you're not surprised to hear the
audience didn't really understand what
we were talking about at the same time
even back then and you know in 2014 i
knew that it was an important idea and i
knew that it was a potentially
transformative idea
it took seven years for nfts to hit the
mainstream
in 2020 around 150 000 nfts were sold on
openc one of the biggest nft trading
platforms
in 2021 more than four times that were
being sold monthly
there were a few things that drove that
boom
the first is covert 19. it seems as
though lock down boredom or stimulus
checks tempted a lot of young people and
new people into dabbling in experimental
kinds of financial markets you saw
bitcoin reaching new all-time highs you
saw the sort of second biggest
cryptocurrency ethereum also reaching
new all-time highs
as crypto wealth grew
the supply of nfts grew with it
new artists started minting nfts in
their thousands
skyrocketing some to previously
unimaginable levels of success
some were shocked when traditional
auction houses like sotheby's and
christie's bought in on the action
[Music]
kesh is a digital artist whose work
featured in one of christie's first nft
auctions
i don't think that 13 year old kesh
would have ever imagined
that she would be selling her artworks
at christie's
next to warhol and some of the greatest
artists that have ever lived
it's just so exciting because it really
just shows the evolution of digital art
in a sense and the fact that it is now
really being considered as a real art
form
on the business side of things the shift
to nfts has been lucrative colleen is
vice president of auctions at artnet a
global marketplace for online fine arts
sales
that made the leap to nfts in late 2021
for our art nft inaugural sale the
average transaction price in that sale
showed a two hundred and seventy percent
increase versus the average transaction
price in one of our traditional sales
and likewise a hundred percent of our
buyers in that first sale were new to
artnet auctions we were able to
cultivate an entirely new potential
client base by putting our toes in this
world and i think the runway for growth
there is undeniable
but buying and selling nfts comes with a
lot of risks
for those minting them it can be a legal
quagmire
quentin tarantino learned that the hard
way when he tried to sell the script of
pulp fiction as an nft the typist is the
only person who has ever seen it
uh he was like well that sounds like it
would be a pretty good nft he's now
being sued by miramax who say it's their
intellectual property
for those investing in nfts there's
another real danger inflated prices
those who are thinking of investing in
nfts for investment purposes
the reality is 99 of them might not
trade on the secondary market for much
of anything
skeptics say the whole market is a ponzi
scheme where those who got in early are
now making money as new buyers enter the
market and bid up prices
but these flaws haven't stopped nfts
from being widely used they are moving
beyond the world of art and into the
metaverse
[Music]
virtual worlds like these are growing in
number and scale you can read our
coverage on them by clicking the link
above
nfts could be the building blocks for
digital economy within these spaces the
things you buy be it a hat for your
avatar or a plot of land can be
purchased as nfts
but some gamers are skeptical they worry
that this is just another way for video
game companies to make money from
players
big brands are also seeing dollar signs
adidas for example has started making
metaverse ready digital clothing
but nfts could also have more serious
uses
being able to securely document and
track ownership could open up some
powerful new possibilities
at their core nfts are just unique
digital representations of assets and
that could essentially apply to any
asset be it real world or digital a
university degree for example could be
issued as an nft
a degree living securely on a blockchain
and verified by the university would be
near impossible to fake
and could be linked up to existing
online sites like linkedin
nfts in real estate could streamline the
process of buying a home you could dream
up hundreds or thousands of different
ways to potentially use that technology
but if nfts are to become more widely
used there needs to be a lot of
innovation
the lack of a middleman means there's no
one to help if there are any mistakes in
a transaction
handling nfts is also expensive
adding nft to a blockchain involves
paying fees known as gas which fluctuate
wildly and can end up costing a lot
we paid around 98
to sell hours
the carbon cost can also be high
most nfts are issued on the ethereum
blockchain and the network of computers
that maintains the ethereum blockchain
uses an awful lot of energy to do it the
carbon cost of our auction was about the
same as a long-haul economy flight
there are thousands of startups trying
to find solutions to these problems it's
a time reminiscent of the dot-com boom
when market madness surrounded a new
technology
but when the dust settled the internet
became the backbone of our society
could the same happen with nfts
there's both investment potential
there's trading potential and there's
very functional potential as well in so
far as things authenticate or provide
proof of ownership so i think gold rush
absolutely paradigm shift absolutely
and on the precipice of a new
era really right now nfts especially
those linked to digital artworks are
over-hyped and overpriced
but the technology is worth watching
closely it's possible that when
collecting a degree or buying a house
our future could lie with nfts thank you
for watching for more of our coverage on
decentralized finance and nfts please
click the link and don't forget to
subscribe